Let me tell you
about the fifth-grade students
at Boze Elementary School in Tacoma.
They spend the entire school year
planning to colonize
the planet Alpha Centauri
to preserve future generations.
They will get there
on a multigenerational spacecraft
so that the grandkids
of the people on the ship
will arrive at Alpha Centauri,
ready to start a new civilization.
Now projects like these usually start
with a guiding question,
and theirs is "How do you sustain life
for a generation on a spacecraft?"
These 10-year-olds
get into initial conversations
about governance on the spacecraft,
the necessities to have on board.
Is it even ethical to have a generation
live and die on a spacecraft?
And what roles are needed
to create a functioning community?
There are some whispers and some head nods
as the teacher explains to them
that this quarter,
they're expected to deliver
a persuasive essay,
a 30-second elevator speech,
a model of a section
of the spacecraft in diorama form,
a system of government
with laws and a constitution,
and a research display
demonstrating their knowledge of planets.
That's a lot.
(Laughter)
But these students aren't fazed,
they'd been here before.
What they're interested in
is what group they'll be in
and what roles they will play.
Now I don't know about you,
but when I was in fifth grade,
I wasn't doing that.
(Laughter)
But for many of these students,
they have been learning like this
since kindergarten.
You heard that right, kindergarten.
Shoot, when I was in fifth grade ...
we sat in cemetery rows
in academically segregated classrooms,
and sadly, things have not changed.
In most schools, students are sitting,
listening to the teacher,
and many of them scared to death
they'll get called on
to answer a question.
And too often,
students are totally deflated,
because the teacher is spending more time
on classroom management
than engaging them.
So these students
and the generations behind them ...
they are our talent pool
for everything from community organizing
to running business,
to running government,
and everything in between.
And as it stands,
our public education system
is not cultivating future leaders.
And in particular,
students of color are constantly
devalued and marginalized.
Regardless of background,
students need to envision themselves
as successful in life.
And how teachers deliver the lessons
plays a big role in that.
The most common way to teach
is through a textbook
or a series of textbooks
and a scripted curriculum.
And then, let the test decide
if the students learned anything.
And while you get coverage,
it leaves little room for student voice,
exploration, intellectual rigor
and academic risk-taking.
This is schooling, not educating.
And the long-term impact
is that students likely won't have
that autonomous spirit
they need in the work environment.
This is not what most teachers
signed up for.
It's not.
I don't think there's a single
teacher candidate
that said, "I want to be a teacher
so I can help kids pass
standardized tests."
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Twenty-five years ago,
I left my 17-year tech career
and cofounded a nonprofit
that prepared students of color
for jobs in the tech industry.
And over time,
we learned about our students' experiences
in the public education system,
and we began to wonder what would happen
if we rebuilt public schools
to develop the genius in every student
and give them the tools
to be critical thinkers,
problem solvers, ideators and leaders.
So we got a bunch of educators
to help us answer that question.
Today, my job is to set
the vision and strategy
for how we partner with public schools
to create collaborative,
anti-racist learning environments
grounded in equity,
where students can actively participate
in their own education,
instead of memorizing for tests,
where the curriculum is delivered
in a way that supports
the needs of our students.
Where professionals in the community
are invited to participate
in teaching and learning.
The teaching and learning is built
on interdisciplinary
project-based learning.
One of the most equitable ways to teach.
This approach enables teachers
to understand how each student learns,
use multiple ways
to assess their knowledge
and then make instructional adjustments
based on the results.
You know, students, they get a chance
to set their own goals.
They have time to discuss the work.
They take academic risks.
And along the way,
they get to discover
who they are as learners.
And speaking of learners,
let's take a visit
to our fifth-grade Alpha Centaurians,
and listen in as their teacher
facilitates a discussion
about how Native Americans live.
They talk about the logistics
and the preparation behind
the colonizers' move out West,
and how colonizers always had conflicts
with Native Americans.
And the students vow
that they will do better
on Alpha Centauri.
They will ensure that everyone
has equal rights and lives well.
And you better believe
it will be part of their constitution.
And if you poke your head
in the classroom next door,
which is rather loud,
you will see the kids
are in their small groups,
using their math skills to calculate
the human capacity for their spacecraft.
And another set of students
will be working on their planet research.
When we visit, a week or so later,
there might be a visiting engineer
talking to the students
about design specifications.
Or the classroom could be empty
because the students
are at the Museum of Flight,
sitting in real spacecraft
and learning how they work.
Bringing that authentic
context to learning
helps students retain knowledge
and generate new ideas.
After weeks and weeks
of working on their projects
and giving each other authentic,
supportive feedback,
and doing that fine-tuning,
the students are ready for the big day --
the exhibition of learning.
This is where hundreds of people
from the community,
the most important members
being their parents and families,
come to see the students
present their work.
The students are all dressed up.
They're a little nervous,
they're excited at the same time --
kind of like me right now.
(Laughter)
And the teachers are beaming with pride
as they recognize how far each student
has come in their learning journey.
OK, and the parents?
The parents are high-fiving,
and "You get it, girl!"
And "That's my baby," and "You go, boy."
And there's just so much praise.
And the students feel accomplished
and more confident.
This is project-based learning in action.
These students are developing
the advanced critical thinking skills
they will use throughout their lives.
They are learning through exploration.
There is confirmation
their unique voice matters.
These students have the freedom
to create a world,
with their ten-year-old imaginations,
that's actually grounded
in academic rigor.
This is educating ...
versus schooling.
Yeah?
(Cheers and applause)
There is teacher support,
diverse interactions ...
team-building
and practical application of reading,
writing, math and science.
An environment where real
learning is happening,
and students are discovering
their own genius.
Plus, I have to say,
it's just a lot of fun to learn this way.
(Laughter)
Students who attend
our partner schools ...
learn this way in every single stage
of their academic career.
Starting in kindergarten,
students are encouraged
to share their views,
to ask questions and support each other.
They are creating a community
and an environment that is safe
and their own.
In middle school,
the students are starting
to become socially aware.
They care about things like world hunger,
immigration and homelessness.
One year,
the seventh-graders
at TAF at Saghalie in Federal Way
turned their classrooms
into an immigration museum
exploring the historic and contemporary
issues of immigration.
And the sixth-graders use food to learn
about each other's cultures.
They created cookbooks
with recipes and stories
from their countries of origin.
And then on exhibition night,
they cooked for everybody,
and it was actually pretty good.
(Laughter)
By the time students get to high school,
they have enough experience
that they can address a wide range
of issues and opportunities.
A group of 10th-graders
created wearable technology
that detected the flare-up signs
in sickle-cell anemia.
Experiencing gentrification
in their own neighborhoods,
11th-graders created plans and models
for equitable, financially sustainable
urban neighborhoods.
The list goes on and on.
This ...
This is how we develop the strong,
the strong leaders
and critical thinkers of tomorrow.
Our students deserve to learn
in an environment that includes
and understands their unique voice,
their individual genius.
If we are going to rebuild
public education,
we have to be on a continuous cycle
of recognizing, intentionally undoing,
and, ultimately, replacing
the institutional practices
that undereducate and harm our children.
And there are a couple of things
that we can do right now.
We could reallocate
the tens of millions of dollars
each state spends
on standardized tests every year.
(Applause)
Alright.
And we can invest the majority of that
in teacher professional development
so that our teachers can continually hone
their instructional and assessment skills.
And then, we could take the rest
and invest it in a national effort
to curate authentic assessment methods
and projects from teachers
all over the country.
I believe that this will bring joy
and respect
back to teaching.
We also need to embed racial equity
in the DNA of how we operate schools.
(Applause)
Achieving racial equity is a journey
that requires dedication,
consistency and accountability.
It needs to be normalized
as part of the daily practice
of principals, administrators,
teachers and staff.
We can do this.
We can.
All it takes is political will.
Education either functions
as an instrument
to bring about conformity
or freedom.
Let’s give our children
freedom.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)